cottage finally I'm great amazing place
Monique Keizo is one of New Zealand's
top chefs trained in Michigan star
restaurants but passionate about her
Maori heritage she's on a one-woman
mission then the food of her ancestors
with the world of fine dining now or
never ever ventured into that married
cuisine so what do I need to understand
there's four main ecosystems
there's the oceans in the river its
tongue at all god of the sea and then
there's the mountains and the forest
papatuanuku earth mother
Papa what Papa - enugu okay Papa to the
worker to a new pepper to a new COO
that's the one it's a complex cuisine
there's a lot of customs involved it's
not just about growing food and just
making it there's a lot of like
different traditions that are interwoven
and all of the food the Mary first
arrived in New Zealand on pioneering
voyages from Polynesia in the 13th
century although they brought some crops
with them much of their diet relied on
hunting and gathering from the forest a
notion a tradition which Mary chefs like
money are keeping alive through their
cooking
now foraging is it big on the menu here
it is big on the menu here a lot of the
time it's the only way to get your hands
on these ingredients well and as you can
see I've got two machetes one of which
is for you
that's my machete that's your machete
I'll throw the ships at my restaurant we
all own a machete English oh but you
don't want to go but night with this
thing dude no you were talking it over
okay with your backpack machetes are
lethal monique is a woman I'm definitely
not going to argue with especially
wishes on the hunt for wild food so this
is not like walking down a supermarket
aisle no this is the hard work we do to
get the food we need to eat they're
everywhere
Monique really yeah
but these vines are more than just a
jungle gym at their tip is a secret very
delicacy so these are the young shoots
that come off the vines and is super
tender Wow you can eat that you can eat
that they're hard to find as a bush
asparagus give it a try so soft and
delicate yeah delicious all I can see in
this tangled forest are potential
personal injury claims oh here's a good
one
but for machete Monique it's like an
all-you-can-eat buffet what's that
hotter pizza it's a native bush pepper
tree wow it's so spicy super peppery
have a munch on that Wow boy 5 people
that is spicy that's incredible from
that quite numb down my tongue yeah
from hot there's now a full-scale forest
fire in my mouth but one eats not done
yet it's amazing from the beach it
doesn't look that steep she's got
another surprise for me high up in the
forest canopy is deep in their money I
know it's a good workout is it nukes
challenge this is a fuchsia tree the
best thing about this tree the berries
and they're usually way up high so the
best one is it bright purple and it's
super sweet yeah but they're just a bit
of a pain to get just shake the tree
will drop down no you're gonna have to
go up seriously yeah you saw they'll
take my weight the Bronson well soon
find out
[Music]
oh wait here that's very kind of you
[Music]
honestly we said come foraging right
yeah say it would all be on the ground
Tarzan up there you see them I can see
that right in front of you
right
lucky house windy
[Music]
so the bright purple ones right bright
purple those the ones were after you
toss them down they look like tiny dates
Wow how good are those it's almost like
a treetop desert I just think that
they're one of the best ingredients that
we have in this country that bloody
tasty future berries fuchsia berry
pretty hairy scaling that tree
especially the wings but another hidden
gem and what a delicious vanilla berry
there's no seeds inside so that's nice
thing so it's just bursting with flavor
depending the ask loss there are the top
of the tree got the bottom want to see
more for my uncharted adventures please
click here to watch more clips